oh what's up
you see that knife kill so what is that
boss thing
dude this guy's huge hey guys this is
vadim with max tech
and this is the video that a lot of you
guys were asking and waiting for
we've got the ipad air 4 right here and
the 2020 ipad pro and what we're going
to do in this video is play a couple of
games
and we're actually going to see the
battery life we're going to be stressing
the performance and battery life on
these two
to see which one does a better job in
terms of the gameplay
the gaming experience and of course the
battery life
now the reason i really wanted to do
this video is because the ipad air 4
has the same chip as the iphone 12 the
a14 bionic
and according to mr who's the boss the
battery life on the iphone 12 lineup
is worse than on the 11 pro because they
have smaller batteries
and that's even without 5g on now phone
arena did their own
battery life test and it was interesting
to see that for browsing
the iphone 12 pro destroyed the 11 pro
by around four hours it actually got
much better but when it got to gaming
the iphone 12s drained the battery like
crazy they died in just
3 hours compared to 6 or 7
with the iphone 11s now i think that's
because of the a14 bionic chip
and to make it even more interesting the
graphics performance on the iphone 12
is limited to around 9 500 points but on
the ipad air 4
it's fully unlocked we're getting around
12
500 metal score which actually beats out
the ipad pro which is totally incredible
it's insane that they got this much
graphics performance out of the 4 core
814
so as you guys can see we've got the
ipad ear 4 right here it's at 100
battery life
it's at 100 brightness and it actually
took the ipad
pro and lowered the brightness just
slightly so it matches up to the ipad
air perfectly
by using the zebra stripes on my top
camera
and of course we've got the xbox
controller which we're gonna use to play
call of duty mobile and
pubg so let's get right into it so here
we are
in call of duty mobile let's take that
down so 100 battery life let's unplug
the connector right here so 1104
one hour from now we're going to check
on the battery life going into the
graphics settings
as you guys can see we're at high and
max so that's 60 fps we've turned on
these extra settings
now we're not going to be taking
advantage of the 120 promotion on the
ipad pro
just to keep the battery life aspect of
it completely fair
so far everything's very smooth oh get
out of here bro
everything's very smooth and we do have
the a7
s3 camera above so it's recording
at a perfect 60 fps but this is kind of
weird it
almost feels like i'm getting some drop
frames i don't understand
why because the a14 gets crazy graphics
performance
i don't know it doesn't feel perfect
doesn't feel like 60.
got him got him
get out of here bro look at that
32 kills zero deaths saw somebody run by
here
oh look out bro
get out of here bro
oh come on triple kill there you go
that's what i like to see nice
wait did that not win it for us i
thought we were gonna win
oh he got me
the one time i died right before the end
[Music]
i died again
not bad 40 to 2 i want to show you guys
i'm playing ranked
drop frames there a little bit that's
not that's not good man
nuclear bomb
i hope i don't die there you go
nice
got him almost there
got him
oh look at that triple q
nice what's up
i've had a nuke every single match
playing ranked
37 to zero this time that's much better
all right there's one guy there's
another
there's another there's another oh come
on right where you at
there you are headshot boom headshot
okay i'm getting dropped frames again
it's gonna be very interesting to see if
we get dropped frames on the pro as well
in this game
because this i mean you can't play like
this alright so it's been just about
30 minutes playing call of duty mobile
now i'm gonna switch to pub
g on this ipad air but you guys are
gonna go into the future
and you're gonna check out the call of
duty mobile performance on
the ipad pro all right and now here we
are on the 2020 ipad pro
as you can see it's 12 23 we're at 100
battery life let me unplug
this charging cable from the side there
you go we don't need that let's set a
timer
set a timer for one hour as you guys can
see graphics quality we have on high
and max 60 fps just like before we have
all these settings
turned on and i already noticed that the
speaker quality is better with those
quad speakers i'm getting more kind of
bright and crisp highs
[Music]
come on get out of here bro double kill
[Music]
got him
oh i almost had that dude
headshot got him
headshot baby come on
oh i almost had him got him
what up watch this
oh what's up
oh come on laser mini this guy's that
guy is not a bot
i'm scared oh what's up
whoa still shooting
i'm still getting head shots watch this
watch this man i'm scared
oh triple kill triple kill
winner winner chicken dinner nice
it's starting to place me with better
players that's for sure
[Music]
got him
you see that knife kill
got him can't carry all of you guys
even going 27 to 7 we just got destroyed
dude get on our way man got him
hedge those two headshots in a row
what headshot
got
got him
got him whoa
triple cool there you go
30 to three that's better
look at that triple q we won nice
you beat 66 percent of players in ranked
really
triple q what's up
uh quadruple kill come on quadra kill
what's up 31 to 2 playing in elite
not bad well that was over 30 minutes
playing
call of duty mobile so let's go ahead
and switch over to
pub g all right now we're playing some
pub g on the ipad air 4
we're here in the graphics settings now
we chose extreme
fps that's actually 60fps and we have to
go with balanced graphics which kind of
sucks but
we have anti-aliasing enable just to
spice it up a little bit apparently pubg
doesn't support
controllers i guess we're gonna have to
play it like this yo yo
there he is what's up bro
get out of here bot now one of the best
things about this new ipad air 4
compared to the previous generation
is now you get speakers on both sides
the top
and the bottom you don't get quad
speakers like the ipad pro which sounds
so much better but you do get them on
both sides so that means when you're
playing games like this
you can actually hear the footsteps
around you
and you can kind of track where they are
it's actually very useful
oh see somebody
oh i got him too so what is that boss
thing i don't know what we're gonna find
out get out of here bro
oh no dude
this guy's huge what in the world dude
oh okay i can't run from him oh dude
hey what's up dude get out of here oh no
okay oh i almost died oh someone is
trying to kill me
what's up so i feel like i'm not getting
perfect 60 fps
there goes my timer as you guys can see
right there it is 1204 and we are at 73
battery life not bad one hour playing
call of duty mobile and
pubg 73 battery life just like before we
got the graphics on balance
extreme turn on the anti aliasing so we
got 60 fps we're limiting it on
the ipad pro to make sure it's fair for
the battery life test between the two
what i noticed so far is that for call
of duty mobile
the air 4 was actually dropping a little
bit of frames
but the ipad pro was perfectly smooth
no issues at all even though the
air actually has more graphics power so
let's see how it does for pubg mobile
man those speakers are good
much better than the ipad air whoa
he's right there
got him
got him too come on man yo
[Laughter]
nice it's gonna go along the coast
no biggie oh
ah all right i'd say that call of duty
mobile is so much more fun than this
game
got him you always behind me
and that is why you want quad speakers
or at least
stereo speakers on your ipad
whoa
got em another bot bites the dust
and there you go there is our one hour
timer
what do we got 123 you guys see 75
battery life so now before i give you
guys my conclusion i want to finish out
this level real quick because i'm almost
done
got em what's up all right there you
guys go that was one hour gameplay on
both the ipad air 4
and the ipad pro and this is my final
conclusion
we did get better battery life on the
ipad pro with the a12z chip compared to
the a14 on the ipad air
we got 75 compared to 73 but honestly
it's just so close that it doesn't
really matter
now on the other hand there are a couple
of major disadvantages for the
air first of all it only gets dual
stereo speakers which sound
so much worse if you guys want to hear a
speaker comparison definitely watch the
which ipad to buy in late 2020 video
that we posted
and on top of that even though the ipad
air 4 has a little bit more graphics
performance
in geekbench 5's metal test we actually
experienced
dropped frames multiple times now i
don't know why that is happening
maybe it's optimization issues with the
a14 or something else like that but
we are getting a better overall
experience with the ipad pro and we
didn't even use
the 90 hertz mode that we have available
in pubg mobile
and in other games we obviously get the
full
120hz pro motion which is just so
great you don't get those things on the
ipad air 4 so
to be completely honest i would skip out
on the ipad air just go for the 2020
ipad pro
or you could wait just a few more months
within half a year we are getting a new
2021 ipad
pro with the a14x chip so
there you guys have it hopefully you
guys enjoyed this video and if you did
go ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe
for more videos like this one and
definitely check out the which i've had
to buy video
right over there thank you guys for
watching and we'll see you
in the next video